[Music]
I'm here with melody winner of the 2018
excellence in theater education award to
talk with her students about the impact
arts education has had on my life which
has been pretty huge we are so happy to
have you here at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas Shantay it has been a privilege
working with you and we're so grateful
and thankful to Carnegie Mellon
University and the Tony Awards Carnegie
Mellon your alma mater for letting you
be here with us it's well it wasn't that
long ago that I was in high school and
then a drama student at CMU and now I'm
working as a professional actress it
seems like theater education really
helps you to see your future and then
your teacher helps you to be your future
yeah teachers really are something
special let the teacher in your life
know how you feel
visit Tony Awards calm and enter the K
through 12 drama teacher that made a
difference in your life I like the way
you said that line a plus
[Music]
you